[Música]
es hora de hablar de economía aquí en
Francia 24 pero yo me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge
bienvenido hay tensión previo a la
Cumbre de presidentes del mercosur que
se celebrará el 6 de diciembre en
Montevideo Valentina y es que esta
semana Argentina Brasil y Paraguay
hicieron una declaración en conjunto
contra Uruguay en mercosur los tres
países dijeron reservar el derecho a
represalias en Montevideo insiste en
negociar acuerdos bilaterales sin la
autorización de todo el bloque la
atención escaló tras la visita del
canciller uruguayo Francisco bustillo en
Australia y Nueva Zelanda donde
precisamente estuvo presentando
formalmente el ingreso de Uruguay al
acuerdo transpacífico un pacto que
representa el 13% del producto interno
bruto mundial Uruguay también ha buscado
acercamientos comerciales con china algo
que ha generado inquietudes en este
bloque el presidente Luis lacalle Pao ha
dicho que quiere cerrar estos tratados
pero permanecer en mercosur para
analizar lo lo que significa esta fisura
previo a la Cumbre del mercosur
conversamos antes con Magdalena Baz
vicio investigadora y doctora en
relaciones internacionales de la
Universidad Nacional de la plata e
integrante también del Sistema Nacional
de investigadores de Uruguay le
preguntamos qué sigue tras esta disputa
protocolo de Olivos la realidad es que
el protocolo de Olivos se ha accionado
muy pocas veces tal vez este podemos
recordar algún caso como el vinculado al
corte de rutas o el vinculado a los
neumáticos remoldeados en los cuales
justamente ha sido Uruguay el que inició
en esos en esos casos los procedimientos
ahora bien qué es lo que implicaría
implicaría un proceso
largo con muchas etapas en las cuales
dependiendo de de Cuál es el camino que
que decidan habría un tribunal ad hoc
que se crea para el caso concreto que
luego de las consultas estas consultas o
sea en una negociación directa no dan
no llegan a buen Puerto se pasa ese
tribunal que se crea para el caso
concreto ese tribunal eventualmente
Podría tener una decisión Bueno pero
Jorge qué es lo que argumentan las
partes bueno por un lado la calle Pou
dice que Uruguay no viola ninguna
cláusula cuando negocia sin la
autorización de sus socios pero el resto
de países reclaman que las normas de
este mecanismo solo permiten a sus
integrantes negociar acuerdos de Libre
Comercio en bloque y vetan los
acercamientos individuales los datos
oficiales muestran que Uruguay envió el
27% de sus exportaciones al bloque en
los primeros 10 meses de este año
mercados como el brasileño son claves
para Uruguay en el sector de lácteos y
mientras que son dependientes de
Argentina en el sector manufacturero
Uruguay se queja también de que el
arancel externo común que rige para los
socios de mercosur encarece
innecesariamente según ellos sus
importaciones sobre esto opinó nuestra
invitada
que no coincide con la de Brasil y con
la de Argentina hagamos esa aclaración
porque
está el kit de la cuestión y abona a
estos
los conflictos que puede haber al
interior del mercosur seamos por la
propia matriz productiva de Uruguay se
encarecen sus importaciones Pero algunas
de esas importaciones son insumos para
producir por tanto producir en Uruguay
termina siendo costoso por el arancel
externo común o sea no es solo que los
bienes que se vayan a comercializar ya
para el consumidor final en Uruguay sean
costosos sino también que la producción
que se requiere para tanto abastecer el
mercado interno como para la exportación
necesite
esos insumos importados y ahí está el
kit de la cuestión Jorge y entonces con
esta situación qué es lo que se espera
para la Cumbre bueno la última vez que
el presidente uruguayo y su homólogo
argentino se encontraron en esta Cumbre
hubo un incómodo intercambio entre ellos
ahora con la solicitud formal al acuerdo
transpacífico de parte de Uruguay y los
reflectores sin duda estarán sobre las
represalia con las que amenazaron el
resto de Los Socios Bueno pues a usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica lo invito a que se quede con
nosotros que ya continuamos aquí con la
sección una semana en el mundo con mi
compañero Santiago López González